andrew cuomo remains defiant today
and at this hour claiming he never
touched anyone inappropriately
and refused to resign and never actually
did anything wrong as governor
ever but all seeming to have zero impact
on the growing calls
from within his own democratic party for
him to leave
and resign here's cuomo earlier today
take a look
i now understand that i
acted in a way that made people
feel uncomfortable and i want you to
know this from me directly
i never touched anyone
inappropriately and you are right you
can
find hundreds of pictures
of me making the same gesture
with hundreds of people women
men children etc
you can go find hundreds of pictures of
me
kissing people men women
it is my usual and customary way
of greeting i'm not going to resign
i work for the people of the state of
new york they elected me
and don't forget it was andrew cuomo
himself who was the first to call for
many others to resign immediately amid
harassment allegations
one government watchdog told the new
york post quote not so long ago
governor cuomo demanded two assembly
members immediately deny allegations or
resign
powerful words does the governor now
hold himself to the same standard
and remember it was cuomo who was an i
believer himself
also wanting justice kavanaugh to take a
lie detector test
so is the governor going to hold himself
to that same standard
will he take a lie detector test now of
course if the media mob had any
real ethics any real standards andrew
cuomo would have been under fire
long ago for what is the biggest nursing
home
death cover-up in the country we've
covered it on this program from day one
but from the very beginning of the
pandemic
the mob the media was rarely interested
in any serious coverage of cuomo
while he was out there talking into him
powerpoints donald trump was building
hospitals
manning hospitals converting manikova
capability
providing every ventilator that he
didn't buy
even though it was recommended by his
health care task force
providing every set of gloves every mask
every gown
every everything that cuomo never used
these hospital beds never used the
hospital ship
to the extent he could have 80 percent
unoccupied
we saw headlines all throughout the
beginning of covid
why we are crushing on andrew cuomo
right now
a piece in the new york times entitled
andrew cuomo
is the control freak that we need
right now some even referred to
themselves as cuomo
sexuals whatever the hell that means i
have no idea
the demands for transparency
accountability should have started last
spring but the mob the media
they were too busy swooning over his
powerpoint press conferences
now here we are one year later governor
cuomo is still refusing to take any
responsibility for the damage the pain
that his executive action caused even
claiming today that he's never done
anything in his public career that he's
even ashamed of although the good news
is some political reality
is beginning to set in as a majority of
new york voters have had it with cuomo
and say that he should not ever be
elected for a fourth term
many want him gone now his approval
rating is now cratered
to 33 points one point during the
pandemic
and his highly quote emmy award-winning
powerpoint presentations it was at 87
percent
how far one has fallen